[Music]
good afternoon and thank you for coming
to listen to me
as you heard I've been here so long ago
before even this university was
established as it is now
it was the mirror Institute and I must
tell you it looks the same most of it
the ceiling is the same
the elevators are the same the flow is
the same people have changed and the
entrance is not for the 5th Avenue but
otherwise I'm really happy to come back
here since I left 50 years ago more or
less 50 years ago I was here only once
invited to give a lecture and they today
so a may collect the statistics that was
given earlier certain pH days today
I think it's 14 because I also got one
[Applause]
and I must tell you that in my opinion
although the ceremonies here are longer
than in many other places it's very
impressive they are very impressive and
people are very friendly and I think it
includes you as part of of this
establishment so I don't really know
what to tell you and what you want to
hear and maybe I will start with a
question that they few questions that
everybody asks me oh not everybody saw
it many times I'm being asked how come
we went on for such a long time on a
project that was considered impossible
and the answer is I was really curious
I was curious since I was five years old
but on this particular point which say
this particular question which I want to
describe now in a few sentences this was
my dream was to understand it so let me
say a few words we all know that DNA has
it in it instructions which are called
genes that according to them proteins
are being produced proteins are the
workers of every living cell from
bacteria cockroaches elephants flowers
whatever they are they are performing
most of the tasks that are needed for
life and they can can function only when
their structure is made for the function
and
is determined by the sequence of the
components that produce the proteins
these components are called the minor
acids there are twenty types of them in
the whole universe and they the order of
this twenty compo twenty types of
components is determining how the
protein will look and what the podium
can do proteins are usually made of 150
to 300 amino acids this component and
the order of them that I just said is
dictating what they can do as machines
as molecular machines is dictated by the
genes the genes that are in the DNA so
the DNA language is made of only four
letters I am still excited about it I
still I still have the whole all our
life are determined by four letters
every combinations of three of them is a
used in order to put in an a minor acid
into the protein they going protein so
this was all known when I I was a young
high school kid and then student the DNA
structure was determined at that time
and also they aim and a location of H
its triplet with the corresponding amino
acid proteins were known to exist and
also it was known that the sequence of
their components is determining their
structure it means their function this
was all known but not how how does have
this happens it happens in every cell
all the time some some cells have the
Machine that translates
genetic code into proteins which is
called ribosomes some have millions of
them in a single cell in the liver
million of ribosomes and these ribosomes
are no sorry no to wait that they code
the genetic code and to produce
accordingly proteins they they read a
language of four letters they are
creative in a world of twenty letters
they work all the time they hardly make
mistake mistake of about 1/2 a million
one to half a million there is some
dispute about it and this these are
actually the machines of life and it was
not known how they work I want to give
you an example my bazooms can make about
40 bones between the components of the
14 in one second with very very little
mistake I was the fastest in my class at
the university second year we had to
make a single bond I was the fastest
because I was very very poor and I had
many jobs that I had to do so I had to
finish with my my lab work as fast as
possible to do all the other jobs and as
a first test I needed 6 hours to make
one bond now chemistry a developed and
it's possible to make a bond in two
hours but not 40 in a second
like the ribosomes make all the time hey
why do their Bibles of make all the time
let me just say one well cells life
don't like long long lasting proteins
they are afraid of mistakes life is
afraid of mr. so proteins are being
killed killed or denature or get
deteriorated and new ones have to come
in and they working blocks for the
proteins the components of core
coming from the proteins that we eat
like eggs and and cheese and steaks and
so on so this is what the cell is doing
all the time the cells are doing all the
time everywhere in every living
organisms including bacteria and it was
not known how and for me this was a very
exciting question I was really curious
about it I really wanted to understand
it I was not the only one there were
several other groups led by more
distinguished scientists with much more
experience that then a new a new fresh a
scientist like I was at that time and
they failed some of them have been and
still are very distinguished so I
thought if I also failed I joined a good
group of fellows but my curiosity was
stronger than me and we continued I
don't think that I want to go now on to
all the problems and all the questions
and all this but after 20 years we got
the structures and we understand the
function and I think that they take a
lesson for your new graduates curiosity
is is the driving force don't give up if
something excites you and if you're
curious about something
of course if something of meaning in
life in nature in space in whatever you
are interested so this is one thing I
wanted to stress curiosity and passion
know when I was young I didn't even know
that there is a profession called
scientist as I told you we were very
poor my parents had knows a difficult
any similar education and I I thought
that
how come somebody will pay for somebody
else that works on him or his hobby I
looked at answering questions that I was
curious about as I hope me and I didn't
think that hobby can be painful I I
changed my mind when I was already a
student and me I was in at the
University and saw that there are labs
and so on so this is the way I went into
science but still curiosity was and
still is my driving force now my driving
force led leads me into two ideas two
paths that we already mentioned a minute
ago
one is the origin of life I think we
think that we discovered within the
ribosome they a pocket that is where
life started the in the prebiotic time
this is one thing we are trying to do a
prophet and few months ago we got the
first proof and the second is not only
to understand how antibiotics work but
also how resistant to antibiotic
antibiotics is acquired and what can one
do in order to fight against it so let
me say a few words about that
antibiotics that are being used today
all and almost all not all but almost
all antibiotics are natural products
which are the weapons that one bacterial
type is using against enemies other
bacteria and the doctors are using it
when the antibiotics are such that they
don't disturb the patient we don't worry
the bacteria bacteria pathogens because
ribosomes are so important as you heard
a minute ago they produce all the cell
vehicles they are very very a beloved
target to the antibiotics almost half of
the useful antibiotics and paralyzing
ribosomes no new proteins known your
life for the next generation but
bacteria out Leben in many aspects are
cleverer than us at least in survival so
the bacteria found ways to resist the
weapons that are the bacteria produced
against them all ribosomes antibiotics
that are known today paralyzing the
ribosome by stopping one of them
function it's not not needed to stop all
functions just inhibiting one of their
functions like the rate reading of day
of the code or producing the board and
so on it's enough that one of this
function is is done and the ribosome
cannot function and next generation will
not have protein so we'll have one for
things and so on a bacteria found it out
bacteria making made it in on a a
experiments done of all all twice done
by by companies could not overcome that
therefore companies are not are not
making new antibiotics now they are not
investigating in it it's much too
expensive there is very little hope that
there will not be resistance and the
products are not going to be not going
to justify the high investment in the
production in
they in the finding how to make new ones
and this is a read bed situation the
wealth Health Association announced that
they think that in 2020 a there will we
will start to go back to the time before
antibiotics which is beginning of last
century the World Bank estimated that
almost four percent of the global income
will be lost because of antibiotic
resistance by 2050 it's it's a
frightening situation and I could not
sit quiet to say that actually very
little is done against it
although government and the European
community in the g7 in the United States
have acknowledged the problem recently -
a few years ago and started to allocate
more money for more funds for research
they cannot convince the companies to
take off from the results to the
production so we decided in my little
lab to look for new ways for a producing
antibiotics and therefore we determined
the structures of several ribosomes from
a bacteria that are pathogenic and we
are looking for differences in
structures between those in the good
bacteria which are not connected today
functional sites but can stop the
production of fourteens and so far we've
identified a few of them and we are
working on it now so I see that maybe we
can still contribute something to
humanity to the health and so on so
before we finish I want to relate to
another question that I'm frequently
being asked what advice can can I give
to young people - yo guys you
guys in order to whatever they got
scientists though my advice I have only
one advice don't look for advices do
what you think is interesting for you
what you think you can do what you think
will be a suitable or helpful to your
manatee and what you think has an impact
a real question
good luck to a few congratulations and
they I hope to hear about you in the
future
thank you so much
[Applause]